so we try to do animal segments when we
can and we try to highlight the heroism
of people when we can and occasionally
those two topics come together and the
person we're speaking of is former
Denver Bronco defensive lineman Derek
Wolfe so recently a mountain lion had
been stalking and killing dogs in
Colorado in a neighborhood
killing people's dogs so however you
feel about mountain lions you're not
allowed to kill people's dogs so wolf
didn't call the authorities he acted he
grabbed a bow and arrow hiked nearly 10
000 feet up a mountain in the Rockies
and then took out the mountain lion that
had been killing dogs
wolf is obviously a very talented Hunter
and a man of actions we said he's a
former NFL player and sports radio host
he joins us tonight Derek well thank you
so much for coming on tonight thanks for
having me Tucker so this this mountain
lion was killing people's dogs and but
you didn't call Fish and Game you decide
to do it yourself tell us about the
decision
you know Tucker before I get into the uh
specifics of the actual hunt I want to
give some background on um the mountain
lion issue here in Colorado
um since 1990 there's been 23 human
attacks so that means every other year
there's a human being attacked by it by
a mountain lion just last year alone in
a in a town up by Boulder Boulder
Colorado 15 dogs pet dogs were killed in
30 days
and people were calling call Parks and
Wildlife wondering where are you at why
aren't you coming to help us
um so I I got a call from a good friend
of mine his name is Alex Nestor this
wasn't a paid hunt I didn't pay for this
hunt it was just something that I was
interested in doing I love to hunt and
uh he called me and said hey there's a
cat up here
um you want to come help and I said yeah
let's go
so we get up there and the first thing
we see is a full-grown mule deer that he
had drug across the road right across
the street from somebody's house
and it was and then uh we followed those
tracks up to his porch and up on that
point it was up on This Woman's porch
and living underneath of her porch even
when she and when we had talked to the
landowner they said hey we have house
cats and the cats are acting weird we
were wondering why well it's because you
have a full-grown 200 pound eight and a
half foot mountain lion walking across
your front yard and that's why so
um in Colorado you're allowed to use
dogs to get these catch treed because
it's important to see how what kind of
cat you're after right you want to you
want to go after
um full-grown mountain lions full grown
male mountain lions that's what you want
because those full-grown males
um will kill kittens as well they will
kill the kittens to get the female lines
to go back into heat so it's important
to manage that herd right you have to
manage every population of animal out
here especially these mountain lions so
we got the dogs on them and it was the
most I'll tell you I've been through
some tough training camps brother but
this hunt
was uh man it beat me up bad I was beat
up bad I'm all cut up and scraped up I
was in full body cramps
um barely made it up there the cat
itself when we finally got to it was at
uh 9 600 feet altitude and I don't know
if anybody knows anything about altitude
but you're sucking air at that high I
was able to make a good shot a good
ethical shot and
um harvested the cat and
uh got him out of there and did
everything by the book this was
completely legal
um CPW came down and uh checked the cat
in for me I took the meat and got it
processed I'm going to eat that cat it's
going to be I can't believe what's
what's happening to me I can't believe
that going on a legal hunt doing
something legal by the book they've
they've had 200 calls to Colorado Parks
and Wildlife trying to turn me in like I
did something wrong yeah um did nothing
wrong everything's legal
I know you have been and the main reason
I wanted to have you on tonight was just
to remind people who live in Rural
America in urban America that like it's
different when you live in a place where
mountain lions kill people and pets it's
not like Brooklyn at all and so maybe
people should understand that before
they run around making threats against
men like you Jericho if I appreciate
your coming on tonight thank you yeah
thanks for having me brother of course
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight